you know what John Wayne's name was uh
no I don't what his real name Marion
Morrison which by the way is an awesome
name too Fox Studio Chief rejected the
his name as it sounded to Italian kind
of makes John Wayne seem like a little
bit of a [__] doesn't it he could have
said God damn it I'm Marion Morrison and
that's all there is to it he went to USC
which is odd did he play football yeah
he was an athlete he broke his
collarbone which as we all know is a
really cool injury that's pretty [__]
sweet dude yeah did he do it did he do
it shredding
body surfing accident
that's how Marion Morrison used to talk
yeah it's like dude dude dude Marion you
should not be in this wave and he
[__] shredded it and sure enough
snapped his collar balls dude what am I
gonna do now I can't even be an actor I
sounds too Italiano
[Laughter]